por lo que se puede leer en esos
mensajes que circulan en las redes
sociales esta nueva jornada de protestas
un mensaje más al Estado iraní de que
estás movilizaciones no van a parar ya
casi se cumple estamos A pocas horas de
que se cumpla un mes de la detención de
esta joven curda maxante eran por la
policía la moral horas después sería
llevada al hospital con muerte cerebral
también una de las razones para la
convocatoria del día de hoy se debe a la
gran represión que estamos viendo en las
últimas horas en el kurdistán iraní esto
viene dándose desde el comienzo desde
pocas horas después de la muerte de
maxamos que ella es kurda allí empezaron
las protestas no solamente en su ciudad
sino en la capital del kurdistán iraní
en San Andrés Donde ha habido una gran
represión de las autoridades sin embargo
esta se ha aumentado según se ha
conocido y a pesar de las restricciones
de internet en los últimos tres días no
se sabe el número de Muertos pero se
dice que hay bastantes las personas
heridas se habla de Gran presencia de
las autoridades no solamente en San
anddas sino en maribán una población
fronteriza con el kurdistán iraquí es
que irán acusa a dos grandes grupos
opositores kurdos iraníes con base en
Irak de estar promoviendo esas protestas
dentro del país una organización de
Derechos Humanos iraníes que opera en
oslo habla de 201 personas muertas hasta
el momento y dice que muchos de esos
serían en el kurdistán iraní Pero eso
también llegan un momento en el que el
estado
iraní intenta crear lazos o por unos
puentes de comunicación con la población
hoy veíamos Cómo eran está llena de
pancartas con la bandera de Irán y
hablan de la unidad de Irán Y a ella
versiones dentro de algunas autoridades
que hablan de crear diálogos puntos de
encuentro pero hoy el líder supremo
volvía y se refería a estas protestas
como pequeños movimientos aislados que
estaban siendo promovidos desde el
extranjero